we have reason to believe the russian
forces are planning to and intend to
attack ukraine in the coming week
in the coming days
we believe that they will target
ukraine's capital ki
a city of 2.8 million innocent people
we're calling out russia's plans loudly
repeatedly not because we want a
conflict but because we're doing
everything in our power to remove any
reason that russia may give to justify
invading ukraine and prevent them from
moving
make no mistake
if russia pursues his plans it will be
responsible for a
catastrophic and needless war of choice
the united states and our allies are
prepared to defend every inch of nato
territory from any threat
to our collective security as well
we also will not send troops in to fight
in ukraine but we will continue to
support the ukrainian people
this past year the united states
provided a record amount of security
assistance in ukraine to bolster its
defensive
650 million dollars from javelin
missiles to ammunition
we also previously provided 500 million
dollars in ukraine and humanitarian aid
and economic support for ukraine
and earlier this week
we also announced an additional
sovereign loan guarantee of up to one
billion dollars to strengthen ukraine's
economic resilience
but the bottom line is this the united
states and our allies and partners
will support the ukrainian people
we will hold russia accountable for its
actions
the west is united
and resolved we're ready to impose
severe sanctions on russia if it further
invades ukraine
but i say again
russia can still choose diplomacy
it is not too late to de-escalate and
return to the negotiating table
last night
russia agreed that secretary of state
blinken
and foreign minister lavrov
should meet on
on february 24th
february 24th in europe
but if russia takes military action
before that date will be clear that they
have slammed the door shut on diplomacy
they will have they will have chosen war
and they will pay a steep price for
doing so
not only from the sanctions that we and
our allies will impose on russia but the
more outraged the rest of the world will
visit upon them
you know
there are many issues that divide our
nation and our world
but standing up to russian aggression is
not one of them
the american people are united
europe is united the transatlantic
community's united our political parties
in this country are united the entire
free world is united russia has a choice
between war and all the suffering it
will bring or diplomacy
that will make a future safer for
everyone now i'm happy to take a few
questions
nancy from bloomberg uh thank you so
much sir do you think that it is wise
for president zielinski to leave ukraine
if an invasion is as imminent as the us
says it is
that's a judgment for him to make and
the determination as to whether or not
i've spoken with zielinski
a dozen times
maybe more i don't know
and uh and uh it's uh
in in the pursuit of a diplomatic
solution uh it may not be fault
maybe the wise choice
but it's his decision
and do you have any indication about
whether president putin has made a
decision on whether to invade do you
feel confident that he that he hasn't
made that decision already
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that
there seems to be a unanimity of spirit
to do between the united states and
europe to do some sanctions with the
comprehensive sanctions but are is
everyone on board with the exact same
sanctions that you want to do
uh
yes
um there'll be some slight differences
but none there'll be more add-ons than
subtractions
and
president putin is going to oversee some
nuclear drills this weekend how do you
see that happening what's your reaction
to that sir thank you
well um
i don't think he is remotely
contemplating nuclear
using nuclear weapons
but i do think it's
i think he is um
focused on
trying to
convince the world that he has
the ability to change the dynamics uh in
europe
in a way that he cannot
um but i i don't uh
how much of it is a
cover for just saying we're just doing
exercises
and and there's more than that i i just
can't it's hard to read his mind
mr president
mr president to be clear
to be clear you are convinced that you
are convinced that president putin is
going to invade ukraine is that what you
just said a few months ago
yes so is diplomacy off the table then
no because all until he does diplomacy
is always a possibility
what reason do you have to believe he's
considering that option at all we have a
significant intelligence capability
thank you very much
[Applause]
listening there to the u.s president
dramatic news tonight from him you're
watching sky news at 10 then live from
ukraine the u.s president as you saw
they're speaking live from the white
house tonight as the u.s officials say
190 000 troops are on the border of
ukraine significant news then from the
u.s president he believes that president
putin has made a decision to invade
ukraine he believes also that the
capital where i am now kiev will be
targeted a city of some 2.8 million
people let's go live then to the white
house our u.s correspondent martha
kellner standing by for us there and yet
he said diplomacy is still a possibility
martha
yeah he was saying that he was
suggesting the daughter diplomacy is
still open but it seems it may be almost
shot now that incredibly alarming line
from president biden a new revelation
that he believes that president putin
has made his mind up to invade ukraine
he said that he believes russia will
invade ukraine in the coming days he
originally said that they would he
believed that they would invade in the
next week he then revised that to say
days i thought that was significant
president biden said that he believes
that
russia will attack the capital kiev home
to 2.8 million people as he noted we've
certainly not heard that before the
warning from president biden here
incredibly bleak
he made though a direct address to
president putin and he said as you
mentioned there that the daughter
diplomacy is still open up and until he
he makes that decision to invade or
rather he believes he's made the
decision but until he actually commits
that further invasion of ukraine he
delivered this warning to the russian
president he said make no mistake if
russia pursues this plan it will be
responsible for a catastrophic and
needless war of choice that was
something he said three days ago that if
president putin chooses to launch this
further invasion that this will not be a
necessary act this will be something he
and he alone has chosen to do there was
a note of reassurance to to allies
president biden pledging to defend every
inch of nato territory but again
insisting no us troops will go into
ukraine